[Música]
bajo el grito de libertad cientos de
austriacos protestaron contra las
medidas anti cobit decretadas por el
gobierno después de registrar el viernes
un nuevo récord de casos con 15 mil 800
contagios en 24 horas
austria es el primer país de la unión
europea en decretar la vacunación
obligatoria será a partir de febrero de
2022 además desde el lunes entrará en
vigor durante 20 días un bloqueo parcial
que sólo permitirá a la ciudadanía salir
a trabajar
quiero mi libertad de vuelta uno
pensaría que vivimos en una democracia
pero esto es la dictadura del
coronavirus
[Música]
en países bajos también salieron cientos
de personas para protestar contra las
restricciones para acceder a espacios
cerrados sin carné de vacunación así
estaban las calles de ámsterdam y así
las de breda
una imagen muy diferente a la del
viernes cuando en rotterdam dos personas
fueron hospitalizadas con heridas de
bala y más de 50 detenidos en hechos que
el alcalde calificó de [__] de
violencia
en australia pese a alcanzar el 85% de
mayores de 16 años vacunados miles de
personas salieron a las calles de sídney
y melbourne para oponerse a las vacunas
algo que también provocó la respuesta en
las calles de simpatizantes de izquierda
que muestran preocupación por los
negacionistas de ultraderecha
estoy a favor de la vacunación soy de
izquierda y estoy en contra del fascismo
que hay ahora mismo en melbourne una
tensión por la vacunación que cada vez
más se está volviendo un asunto de
disputa ideológico